congratulations on this film you and
your movie Mama looked so hot tonight in
sequins she's such a babe everything I
learned about bathing I learned from
Allison Janney you are you look like a
babe yourself tonight and I saw your
sweet husband walk by and oh is he here
yes didn't I he was yes but we came
separately he I came from hair and
makeup and he came from uh the tattoo
parlor oh new tattoo yeah he just got
some work on the sleeve okay
uh it's like a hawk the finishing of a
hawk this beautiful Hawk that wraps
around his arm okay yeah so on a night
like tonight when you two are all
dressed up Mom and Dad's night out what
did the kiddos say well let's be clear I
think he's in sweatpants just to be
clear
yeah
look at all
everyone's got the sequence memo hey
baby
[Music]
this is my favorite spot yeah right here
you're burrowing that's right she's
sleeping take it quickly you two seem
and you're like who the hell oh my God
all right go back to your thing no
you're so sweet
I love it everyone with the sequence
memos I love it I love it she's very
special it's so special you'd be very
fun wedding guest
um I would love to go to a wedding with
Darcy okay what's date night like what
did the kids say yeah when you come out
when you come out and you're in sequence
all dialed up ready for your big night
what do the girls say well they usually
want to play with the dress because it's
like not at all the Vibes I usually give
off at home they did want to play with
this dress quite a bit and then they're
now at the age where they're fine when I
leave which is great but I did get four
different voice memos on my phone on the
way here about the fact that we didn't
have Oreos and they'd been counting on
Oreos and then what a huge
disappointment I was because I had not
restocked the Oreos yeah I mean there's
no better way to keep you humble right
mom's in a new movie and they are
unimpressed they just want their Oreos
right that's right
no you and Jackson blame them it's a
good cookie listen it's a good cookie
but it's a good movie Mom's in too good
movie too it's a good movie too now you
and Dax are approaching 10 years double
digits together would you do a foul
renewal are we did we just I think we
might have
just had no we just had nine you just
did nine girl the math is hard you gotta
remember kids birthdays and and the
years they were born there's too many
numbers would we do a vowel renewal uh
yeah why not the celebration of weddings
now renewal have the girls be involved
in it yeah but I think it would just be
at our house it wouldn't be like a big
thing yeah that's what you do when you
celebrate a decade with someone what is
the secret I'm approaching I'm getting
married soon so what is the secret when
are you getting married January 2024 in
Cabo you want to come congratulations I
would love Mr Gators unite there'll be a
lot of Midwestern what's the secret
secret stay vulnerable that's like my at
least my secret you've got to be
vulnerable we have to be vulnerable when
we don't want to be that's what works
for us okay yeah and marry your best
friend yeah yeah
[Music]